this village is different
Steve Metzger banya is in the staff
nature mountains in central Slovakia
there's something special in the air
birds of prey are aiding educators here
I was afraid of the birds at first but
not anymore
not even the eagle the school's
principal Pavel Michel is responsible
for introducing birds of prey into the
school curriculum the innovative
educational program saved the school
falconry is a compulsory subject for all
pupils in grades seven through nine but
even the younger kids love it nobodyís
the pupils have to take responsibility
for the birds
they must care for them daily even
during the holidays by working with live
animals they learn to make decisions and
be patient that's very important those
skills have to be learned the teacher
tells the children how to use the
equipment the pupils practice working
with the birds properly Sara show was
how to put the hood on the Eagle even if
the American Bald Eagle Nixon isn't so
crazy about the head where he's teaching
Sara that she must be the boss
the school now has 40 birds they're
quite valuable
some of them are worth more than five
thousand euros the youngest pupils care
for the Owls they feed them dead chicks
and are not in the least afraid the
older children train vultures eagles and
falcons one of the most difficult skills
is learning to place food on the glove
properly the bird should go for the meat
not the pupil it's a great feeling when
the bird does what I trained him to do
even though he's a bird of prey one of
the secrets of Steve Nietzsche banya is
the close bond between people and
animals during the Middle Ages the
region started to be a center for gold
and silver mining but today all that's
left is the label UNESCO World Cultural
Heritage Site the villages 800 residents
live from tourism wood carving and
forestry many are jobless where we are
are mountain villages difficult to
access investors don't come here and
besides you can't build factories in the
UNESCO area let's go the village needs a
plan the concept is only just getting
off the ground and it's as unusual as it
is appropriate it brings nature into the
classroom with wild birds balcony offers
possibilities for the pupils they can
work at airports for breeders or in
shows and if they can't find a job in
Slovakia they can work abroad as well
the pupils get their first experience a
presentations held all over Europe the
Falcons the feathered friends of sheikhs
have already got them first contacts to
the United Arab Emirates
the effort is great and everyone
teachers pupils and their families must
do their part even Sarah's family when
the birds came things changed for them
as long as Sarah was dealing with the
birds at school it wasn't really a
problem at all but since she's been
tending her own Falcons she's got to go
to school on weekends too that's changed
our priorities as a family completely
falconry is Sarah's favorite subject
she's planning for the future and says
she wants to become a veterinarian and
things couldn't be much better for Pavan
Michelle either since he's introduced
falconry 50 additional school pupils
have come in from neighboring villages
the birds saved his school and have
brought a shimmer of Hope to staff nits
cabana and perhaps the whole region